Salut ! Aujourd'hui je sors des Magic Tutos, vous savez c'est le spectacle dont je vous avez parlé avec Bonaf et Jean Sébastien Masset.
Il est là aujourd'hui. Je vous présente JS.
-Bonjour à tous !
JS c'est un vrai ami magicien et quand j'ai écrit le spectacle des Magic Tutos avec Bonaf, j'ai tout de suite pensé à toi à l'époque pour tenir ce rôle.
Et aujourd'hui je vous ai vu sur scène, c'était mortel !
Ah bah je te remercie !
Comme vous savez en ce moment, j'aime bien des fois prendre un petit peu de vacances, surtout quand jai quelqu'un de très talentueux avec moi.
Et JS comme c'est un grand magicien, je lui ai demandé qui me fasse un tour de magie, vraiment.
Il n'y a pas de pipotage , je ne sais pas ce qu'il va me faire.
J'espère que je vais être bluffé.
Si je vois un truc je vous le dis !
Alors Fabien, nous allons testé ton imagination.
Est-ce que tu penses avoir de l'imagination ?
Oui
Ah bah oui oui oui !
Excellent.
Tiens je t'en prie prend une carte.
N'importe laquelle ? Celle que je veux ?
N'importe laquelle, celle que tu veux.
Alors je vais plutôt prendre celle-ci, comme tu ne me la présentais pas.
De toute façon c'est ton jeu de cartes.
Oui, c'est vrai ! *rires* Il a raison c'est mon jeu de cartes à moi.
Tu la regardes, je t'en prie.
Je leur fais voir ou pas ?
Tu peux leur faire voir, ça n'a pas vraiment d'importance...
Alors mets la tête par là, comme ça tu ne verras pas l'écran.
Vas-y, on va la reposer.
Je la mets où je veux ?
Voilà, très bien.
Ok parfait !
Alors euh Fabien, donc tu me disais que tu pensais avoir de l'imagination, à ton avis, à quel degrés ?
Sur une échelle de 1 à 10.
Je pense vraiment être à 9, parce que vous savez tout ce que je fais avec la mémoire, c'est souvent en visualisant
avec l'imaginaire, donc je pense vraiment avoir beaucoup d'imagination.
Je crois, en tout cas j'aimerais le croire
Ok.
Alors on va tester ça, tout simplement avec une carte, en l'occurrence le 3 de trèfle.
Alors il se trouve que le 3 de trèfle est ma carte préférée.
Ah d'accord.
*Rires*
Je me suis dit c'est pas bon du tout !
On part mal.
Tu vas tendre ta main bien à plat.
Je pose le 3 de trèfle dessus.
Tu vas poser ton autre main par dessus.
Et tu vas maintenant imaginer que sous ta main, le 3 de trèfle se transforme tout doucement en ta carte.
D'accord.
En réalité il suffit d'imaginer que l'image qui est sur le 3 de trèfle, se transforme doucement en l'image de ta carte.
Une fois que cette transformation est fini dans ton esprit, tu claques des doigts de la main gauche.
Moi je claque des doigts ?
Oui.
*Clac*
Excellent.
Alors ce claquement c'est important, il permet de partager ton imagination avec moi, avec vous.
De telle sorte que nous allons tous être capable par vidéo interposée de voir ta carte à la place du 3 de trèfle.
Je la retourne ?
Je t'en prie.
C'est eux qui le voit avant moi.
Ce n'est plus le 3 de trèfle.
Et c'est ma carte ! C'est le valet de pique ! Bravo
Alors évidemment, tout ceci n'est que de l'imagination.
Oui.
On est d'accord. Parce qu'en réalité je t'avais mis le 3 de trèfle.
Je n'ai pas repris la carte. Tu as bien posé ta main dessus et je ne l'ai pas reprise.
Donc cette carte, c'est le 3 de trèfle.
Non, ça c'est le valet de pique ça JS.
Non, c'est le 3 de trèfle, mais notre imagination à tous nous fait croire que c'est le valet de pique.
Même à eux apparemment.
Et là vous vous dites que je vous prends tous pour des jambons.
Ouais.
Et non !
J'ai eu peur de ce que t'allais dire. "Jambon" ça va. *rires*
Non ! Evidemment que non.
Et vous allez voir que je ne dis pas n'importe quoi car cette carte, si on la secoue on se rend compte que ça a toujours été le 3 de trèfle.
C'est fou.
Et tout ce qu'on a pu voir depuis le début, n'était que pure imagination.
C'est incroyable !
Et ça veut dire que si moi je veux que ça devienne un 5 de pique, tu penses qu'en le secouant j'arrive à le transformer en 5 de pique ?
Si j'ai l'imagination de me dire...
Moi je pense pas.
Ou je me dis 5 de pique
5 de pique
5 de pique.
Et là ça devient un 5 de pique.
Oh truc de fou ! T'y arrive deux fois d'affilé ?!
Mais c'est parce que t'es un bon maître en fait.
C'est toi qui vient de m'apprendre à faire ça.
C'est ouf ou pas ce qui fait mon pote JS ?
On est à coté des toilettes d'un restaurant et il y a des gens qui passent, ils nous regardent bizarrement...
Et on les voit derrière !
Ah oui, c'est ça ! *rires*
Et on a mis l'autre caméra dans les toilettes.
*Rires*
Est ce qu'on peux mettre ça sur mon MentalVlog s'il vous plaît !
Quant à nous, rendez-vous demain à 11H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !